the 2016 Olympics in Rio kicked off  Friday with an epic star-studded opening  ceremony the spectacle featured music  dancing and all the flavors of Brazil  who learned they won the bid to host the  games way back in 2008 perhaps one of  the more exciting moments Giselle  Bundchen out of retirement and into a  stunning silver gown with a high slit as  she walked the Olympic sized runway  Giselle took to Instagram just before  she hit the stage to share her pride in  representing her home country speaking  of runway the fashion 11,000 athletes  from around the world represented their  home countries in the ceremonies  including Team USA in a head to toe  Ralph Lauren design led by Olympic  swimmer Michael Phelps in a custom  light-up jacket team France in Lacoste  and team Italy in Armani the opening  ceremonies were nothing short of  spectacular